à quelle catégorie de joueurs d'échec
appartient- Yuri aberbach le seul grand
maître centenaire de l'histoire des
échecs et met les classés dans six
catégories différentes d'abord on a les
tueurs ceux qui veulent détruire le
adversaires comme Fisher ou Kasparov
ensuite les combattants qui n' a jamais
rien comme la SCER catégorie numéro 3
les sportifs pour qu' les échecs c'est
comme le tennis on fait sa partie ou son
match et ensuite retour à sa vie
quotidienne comme si de rien n'était
capabanka en est un bon exemple
catégorie numéro 4 les joueurs en tout
genre mordu de car domino petit chevau
Carpo fait partie de ces joueurs là
catégorie numéro 5 les artistes à
l'image de Tal et ses sacrifices
spectaculaire et enfin la 6e catégorie
les chercheurs ceux qui aiment explorer
les ouvertures comme stinis ou hback
lui-même moi perso je me mettrai plutôt
dans les joueurs puisque mes bluffs sont
beaucoup plus efficaces au poker qu'aux
échecs en tout cas hésite pas à me dire
toi dans quelle catégorie tu te vois
puis si aucune ne convient tu peux
inventer la tienne et me le dire dans
les commentaires